so I have the matrix a over here and a
has m rows and n columns so we could
call this an M by n matrix and what I
want to do in this video is relate the
linear independence or linear dependence
of the column vectors of a to the null
space of a so first of all what am I
talking about is column vectors well as
you can see there's n columns here and
we can view each of those as an M defect
M a dimensional vector and so let me do
it this way so you could view this one
right over here we could write that as V
1 V 1 this next one over here this would
be V 2 V 2 and you would have n of these
because we have n columns and so this
one right over here would be V n V V sub
n and so we could rewrite a we could
rewrite the matrix a the M by n matrix a
and bolding it to show that that's the
matrix we could rewrite it as so let me
do it the same way so draw my little
brackets there we can write it just
express it in terms of its column
vectors is we could just say well this
is going to be V 1 for that column V 1
for that column V 2 for this column all
the way we're going to have n columns so
you're going to have V n for the nth
column and remember each of these are
going to have M terms or I should say M
components in them these are M
dimensional column vectors now what I
want to do I said I want to relate the
the linear independence of these vectors
to the null space of a so let's remind
ourselves what the null space of a even
is so the null space of a the null space
of a
is equal to or I could say it's equal to
the set it's the set of all vectors X
that are members of our N and I'm going
to double down on why I'm saying RN in a
second such that such that if I take my
matrix a if I take my matrix a and
multiply it by one of those X's by one
of those X's I am going to get I am
going to get the zero vector so why do
this why why does X have to be a member
of RN well just for the matrix
multiplication to work for this to be if
this is M by n let me write this down if
this is M by n well in order to just
make the matrix multiplication work or
you could say the matrix vector
multiplication this has to be an N by 1
and n by 1 vector and so it's going to
have n components so it's going to be a
member of RN if this was em by a well or
let me use a different letter if this is
M by I don't know seven then this would
be R 7 that we would be dealing with so
that is the null space so another way of
thinking about it is well if I take my
matrix a and I multiply it by some
vector X that's member of this null
space I'm going to get the zero vector
so if I take my matrix a which I've
expressed here in terms of its column
vectors multiply it by some vector X so
some vector X and actually let me make
it clear that it doesn't have to have
the same so some vector X right over
here draw the other bracket so this is
the vector X and so it's going to have
it's a member of RN so it's going to
have n components you're going to have X
1 as the first component X 2 and go all
the way to X
and if you multiply so if we say that
this X is a member of the null space of
a then this whole thing is going to be
equal to the zero vector is going to be
equal to the zero vector and once again
the zero vector there's going to be an M
by one vector
so you're going to it's going to look
she let me write it like this it's going
to have the same number of rows as a so
I'll try to make it the brackets roughly
the same length so and there we go try
and draw my brackets neatly so I'm going
to have M of these one two and then go
all the way to the M zero
so let's actually just multiply this out
using what we know of matrix
multiplication and by the definition of
matrix multiplication one way to view
this if you were to multiply our matrix
a times our vector X here you are going
to get the first column vector V 1 V 1
times the first component here X 1 X 1
plus the second component times the
second column vector X 2 times V 2 V 2
and we're going to do that n times so
plus dot dot dot X sub n times V sub n V
sub N and these all when you add them
together are going to be equal to the
zero vector now this should be this so
it's going to be equal to the zero
vector and now this should start ringing
a bell to you when we looked at when we
looked at linear independence we saw
something like this in fact we saw that
these vectors V V sub 1 V sub 2 these n
vectors are linearly independent if and
only if any linear if and only if the
solution to this or I guess you could
say the weights
these vectors the only way to get this
to be true is if X 1 X 2 xn are all
equal 0 so let me write this down so V
sub 1 V sub 2 all the way to V sub n are
linearly independent linearly
independent if and only if if and only
if only solution so let me only solution
or you could say weights on these
vectors to this equation only solution
is x1 x2 all the way to xn are equal to
0 so if the only solution here if the
only way to get this this sum to be
equal to the 0 vector is if X 1 X 2 and
X all the way through xn are equal to 0
well that means that our vectors v1 v2
all the way through VN are linearly
independent or vice-versa if they are
linearly independent then the only
solution to this if we're solving for
the weights on those vectors is if for
x1 x2 and xn to be equal to 0 remember
linear linear independence if you want
to say that it's still mathematical but
a little bit more common language is if
these vectors are linearly independent
that means that none of these vectors
can be can be constructed by by linear
combinations of the other vectors or
looking at this way this right over here
is a you could view this as a linear
combination of all of the vectors that
the only way to get this linear
combination of all the vectors to be
equal to 0 is if x1 x2 all the way
through xn are equal to 0 and we proved
that in other videos on linear
independence well if the only solution
to this is all of the X ones through xn
sir is equal to 0 that means that the
null space this is only going to be true
you could say if and only if the null
space of a the null space of a let me
make sure it looks like a matrix I'm
going to bolt it the null space of a
contains one vector it only contains the
zero vector remember this is if all of
these are going to be zero well then the
only solution here is going to be the
zero vector is going to be is going to
be the zero vector so the result that
we're showing here is if the column
vectors of a matrix are linearly
independent
then the null space of that matrix is
only going to consist of the zero vector
or you could go the other way
if the null space of a matrix only
contains the zero vector
well that means that the columns of that
matrix are linearly independent